Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 305 recorded on September 24th, 2006. My name is Connor, and today I recommend a few podcasts to listen to while I'm on paternity leave. Welcome to a solo episode, episode 305, I believe. I'm recording this on Thursday, September 24th at 5.28 p.m. The evening before this is going to drop, I had a backlog. of a couple episodes from the Mark Seraphim interview. Definitely check those out. If you haven't already, we recorded that, Bryce and I and Mark back in July. In anticipation of my wife giving birth to my son,
欢迎收听ADSP播客，第305期，录制于2006年9月24日。我是Connor，今天我推荐几个播客，供我在陪产假期间收听。欢迎来到这期单人节目，我想应该是第305期。我是在9月24日星期四下午5点28分录制的。在这一期节目发布的前一天晚上，我积压了几期Mark Seraphim的采访节目。一定要去听听看。如果你还没听过的话，那是Bryce、我和Mark在七月份录制的。为了迎接我儿子出生，
and I'm very happy to say that she gave birth, and both baby and my wife, Shima, are very healthy, and we are very excited as well as very tired right now. I'm on week two of my paternity leave. I'll be back at work next week and then be taking the rest of my paternity leave later on in the year. or potentially earlier in 2027, but we're taking a bit of a, I wouldn't call it vacation,
我很高兴地告诉大家，孩子已经出生了，宝宝和我的妻子Shima都很健康，我们现在既兴奋又非常疲惫。我正在休陪产假的第二周。下周我会回去工作，然后今年晚些时候或者可能在2027年初再休剩下的陪产假，但我们现在休的这个，我不会称之为度假，
but just a break from work and also podcasting. And therefore, we're just going to have a very brief episode today. So happy to share the news that both my wife and baby are healthy. And we will be resuming our regular schedule of ADSP episodes next week. And potentially we're going to have an interview, maybe maybe not. We'll see. Guest to be announced if we do have a guest.
而只是从工作和播客中休息一下。因此，我们今天只会有一期非常简短的节目。很高兴分享我妻子和宝宝都很健康的消息。我们下周将恢复ADSP的常规节目安排。可能会有一次采访，也许有，也许没有。到时候再说。如果我们有嘉宾，会另行通知。
And for today, I will mention, as I usually do mention, I mean, the last time I looked it up, I did a solo episode was back on January 30th of 2026. So under a year ago, where I was talking about the algorithms that went into the board game mastermind. But I think on previous instances of solo episodes when I wanted to put something out but didn't have that much time. I usually refer people to other podcasts that I have enjoyed as of late, as I do listen to a ton of podcasts.
至于今天，我会像往常一样提到，我的意思是，我上次查了一下，我做单人节目是在2026年1月30日。所以不到一年前，当时我谈论的是棋盘游戏《Mastermind》背后的算法。但我想在之前的单人节目中，当我想发布一些内容但没有太多时间时，我通常会向大家推荐我最近喜欢的其他播客，因为我确实听了大量的播客。
And for those of you that are waiting for Podgod, the process of publishing it has begun. It's going to take a while, probably a couple weeks, maybe a few weeks. But Podgod is coming for those of you that are waiting for the personality meta podcasts. but until then, listen to the following podcasts on whatever app you're currently listening to ADSP on. And the main
对于那些正在等待《Podgod》的人，发布流程已经开始了。这需要一段时间，可能几周，也许几周。但对于那些等待个性元播客的人来说，《Podgod》即将到来。但在那之前，请在你目前收听ADSP的任何应用程序上收听以下播客。而主要的
podcast that I want to put on people's radar is the I think it's like four hours or five hour interview that DHH gave on the Lex Friedman podcast, which is not a podcast that I listen to regularly, but I enjoy listening to DHH's thoughts and interviews that he
我想让大家关注的播客是，我想大概是四五个小时的采访，DHH在Lex Friedman播客上做的，那不是我经常听的播客，但我喜欢听DHH的想法和采访，他
does. and it might be the most inspiring podcast I've listened to in the last decade. He does not work for any of the frontier AI labs or NVIDIA or any company that has a horse in this race. And he beautifully captures my enthusiasm for the AI coding tools, LLMs, etc. that we now have access to. and I encourage you, even if you don't like DHS, even if you don't like Lex Friedman, to go and give that podcast a listen. Another one that came out recently was Jensen, CEO of Vivida, the company I work for, went on the Ezra Klein podcast, which is also not a podcast that I listen to regularly,
所做的。这可能是我过去十年听过的最鼓舞人心的播客。他不为任何前沿AI实验室、NVIDIA或任何在这个领域有竞争的公司工作。他完美地捕捉到了我对我们现在可以使用的AI编码工具、大语言模型等的热情。我鼓励你，即使你不喜欢DHH，即使你不喜欢Lex Friedman，也去听听那个播客。另一个最近出来的是Jensen，我工作的公司Vivida的CEO，他上了Ezra Klein的播客，那也不是我经常听的播客，
although my wife is a big Ezra Klein fan. And the most recent interview was Ezra interviewing Jensen, which is worth listening to. but I was honestly a bit disappointed. There was a couple times when Jensen was asked questions, and I really thought he fumbled the ball. The main one being when he was asked about job displacement, and then Jensen said, you know,
尽管我妻子是Ezra Klein的忠实粉丝。最近的一次采访是Ezra采访Jensen，值得一听。但我老实说有点失望。有几次Jensen被问到问题时，我真的觉得他搞砸了。主要的一次是当他被问及工作流失时，然后Jensen说，你知道，
there's a lot of jobs that didn't exist a number of years or decades ago, and he mentioned a bunch of things, which I don't think were the most compelling examples. And I thought for sure there was an obvious job that was right in front of him that he didn't mention, which was podcasters as for Klein is a full-time podcaster slash journalist. And he didn't mention that. Anyways, I thought that was like a freebie, a layup.
有很多工作是几年前或几十年前不存在的，他提到了很多事情，我觉得这些例子并不是最有说服力的。我本以为有一个显而易见的工作就在他面前，但他没有提到，那就是播客主，因为Ezra Klein是一位全职播客主兼记者。但他没提。总之，我觉得那是一个送分题，一个上篮。
And he didn't mention it. Anyways, I'll leave a link in the description. It's a interesting conversation to listen to, even if I thought Jensen could have performed better. And he really harps on Jeff Hinton, who is actually in my top three people that I like listening to for AI takes. the top three. Ooh, what's the order?
但他没提。总之，我会在描述中留下链接。这是一个值得一听的有趣对话，即使我觉得Jensen本可以表现得更好。他真的在抨击Jeff Hinton，他实际上是我喜欢听AI见解的前三名人物之一。前三名。噢，顺序是什么？
Probably, in no particular order. Boris Churney, who is the creator of Claudecode. He works at Anthropic. Jeff Hinton, one of the fathers of AI, is affiliated with the University of Toronto, although I think he recently retired. And DHS, since his most recent interview with Lex Friedman.
可能，不分先后。Boris Churney，他是Claudecode的创建者。他在Anthropic工作。Jeff Hinton，AI之父之一，隶属于多伦多大学，尽管我想他最近退休了。还有DHH，自从他最近接受Lex Friedman采访以来。
And Jensen gives Jeff Hinton a really hard time for his predictions. He has famously made the radiology and radiologists are not going to have work, and they're going to be displaced. And the opposite happened, Jensen gives Jeff Hinton a really hard time for that. But Jeff Hinton actually went on another podcast
Jensen对Jeff Hinton的预测提出了严厉批评。他曾有名言说放射学和放射科医生将没有工作，他们将被取代。但结果恰恰相反，Jensen为此对Jeff Hinton进行了严厉批评。但Jeff Hinton实际上上了另一个播客
that I listened to more recently called The Big Technology Podcast. And if you follow me on Twitter, you will have seen that I tweeted out a couple clips from that podcast. And he kind of walks back that prediction and acknowledges it was a bad prediction. And anyways, he just has, even if you disagree with Jeff Hinton
我最近听得更多，叫《The Big Technology Podcast》。如果你在Twitter上关注我，你就会看到我转发了那个播客的几个片段。他算是收回了那个预测，并承认那是一个糟糕的预测。总之，他只是有，即使你不同意Jeff Hinton
and his takes that AI is sentient and your P-Doom is nowhere close to his. You know, he famously, or not famously, he has gone on record saying that he keeps his money in three different bank accounts in Canada because he thinks, like, at a certain point in time, due to these like zero-day failures and exploits that LLMs are capable of doing, banks are going to fail and people are going to lose their money. I don't think that's going to happen. But it is interesting, nonetheless, to listen to Jeff Hinton. I have a lot of respect for Jeff.
以及他关于AI是有知觉的观点，你的P-Doom（毁灭概率）与他的相差甚远。你知道，他曾有名言，或者说不那么有名，他曾公开表示，他在加拿大的三个不同银行账户中存钱，因为他认为，在某个时间点，由于大语言模型能够做到的这些零日漏洞和利用，银行将会倒闭，人们将会失去他们的钱。我不认为这会发生。但无论如何，听听Jeff Hinton的观点还是很有趣的。我非常尊重Jeff。
and anyway, so listening to the Ezra Klein podcast where he interviews Jensen, he also cuts in a couple clips, one from an All-In Summit podcast, and then also one from Jeff Hinton. And I was thinking like, oh, it's too bad they didn't splice another clip from Jeff Hinton on the Big Technology podcast because that kind of is the more recent updated take from him. Anyways, so you've got the DHH podcast on Lex. You've got the Ezra Klein interview with Jensen Huang.
总之，听Ezra Klein采访Jensen的播客时，他还插入了几个片段，一个是来自All-In峰会播客的，还有一个是来自Jeff Hinton的。我在想，哎呀，太可惜了，他们没有从《The Big Technology Podcast》中剪辑另一个Jeff Hinton的片段，因为那才是他最近更新的观点。总之，你有Lex上的DHH播客。你有Ezra Klein对Jensen Huang的采访。
You've got the Jeff Hinton podcast from the interview from the Big Technology podcast. And anything with Boris Churney. He was on the platformer podcast, which I actually never heard of, but discovered it, thanks to my personality meta podcast of Boris Churney. And which is, it's crazy that I didn't know that that podcast existed because I believe it is Casey Newton, who is half of the Hard Fork podcast, which is a very popular tech podcast, which actually, I don't think Hard Fork wound down, but Casey Newton, I think is his last name, and Kevin Roos are stepping down from Hard Fork, leaving the New York Times, where I think technically only Kevin Roos worked for
你有来自《The Big Technology Podcast》采访的Jeff Hinton播客。还有任何关于Boris Churney的内容。他上了《Platformer》播客，我其实从来没听说过，但多亏了我的Boris Churney个性元播客才发现了它。这很疯狂，我竟然不知道那个播客的存在，因为我相信它是Casey Newton做的，他是《Hard Fork》播客的一半，这是一个非常受欢迎的科技播客，其实，我不认为《Hard Fork》停播了，但Casey Newton，我想是他的姓，和Kevin Roos正在退出《Hard Fork》，离开《纽约时报》，我想技术上只有Kevin Roos为
the New York Times, and Casey worked for his own company platformer, which is where he has the second podcast with, which is crazy that I didn't know that that existed. And they are going off on own and starting a new podcast, which I think starts either in October or early 2027. They had conflicting statements on their last episode. And it's called machine gods. So if he haven't heard a hard fork, it's pretty great. I mean, not my favorite podcast, but it's something that I look forward to listening to every week. And now that has wound down at least with those two at the helm, and they're going to be doing machine gods. And the reason I brought all that up is because Boris Churny was and his personality meta podcast via Podgod is what led me to discover that Casey Newton
《纽约时报》工作，而Casey为他自己的公司Platformer工作，他在那里有第二个播客，这很疯狂，我竟然不知道它的存在。他们要单干并开始一个新的播客，我想在十月或2027年初开始。他们在上一集里有相互矛盾的陈述。它叫《Machine Gods》。所以如果你没听过《Hard Fork》，它很棒。我的意思是，不是我最喜欢的播客，但这是我每周都期待收听的东西。现在随着那两人的掌舵，它已经结束了，他们将要做《Machine Gods》。我提到这一切的原因是因为Boris Churney以及他通过《Podgod》进行的个性元播客，引导我发现了Casey Newton
had his own podcast called Platformer. Anyways, I have rambled on long enough. I will link all of these different podcasts in general and the specific episodes that I have alluded to. And if I had more energy right now, which I don't, I would splice in all the different clips. Instead, I'll just leave you with the, I think, three or four clips that I already have tweeted out, so it'll be easy enough for me to go and get the audio from that. And I'll put them here. And that will be the end of episode 305. Like I said, we'll be back to our regularly scheduled programming next week. Until then, have a good one. I'm in a state of delirium. That's what the state I'm in. Because I have been working with
有他自己的播客叫《Platformer》。总之，我唠叨得够久了。我会链接所有这些不同的播客，以及我提到的具体剧集。如果我现在有更多精力，但我没有，我会剪辑所有不同的片段。相反，我只会留下我认为我已经转发的三四个片段，所以我去获取音频会很容易。我会把它们放在这里。这将是第305期的结尾。就像我说的，我们下周会回到常规节目。在那之前，祝你一切顺利。我处于一种谵妄状态。这就是我所处的状态。因为我一直在与
computers for 40 years. And I've never seen. seeing the things that I've seen in just the last two months. Yeah. A whole career, a whole life, dedicating to the love of computers as my main focus for the working hours and then some, suddenly completely upended, suddenly completely rewritten. Of course I'm delirious. Who looking at this reality is not?
计算机打交道40年了。我从来没有见过。见过我在过去两个月里看到的事情。是的。整个职业生涯，整个人生，致力于对计算机的热爱，作为我工作时间的主要焦点，然后突然完全颠覆，突然完全重写。我当然会谵妄。谁看到这个现实会不谵妄呢？
If you are not delirious or, at the very least, very excited. Actually, I guess that's not even true. If you're not recognizing the gravity of the moment, that's the dilution. That's the psychosis. The psychosis is believing that the world is barely different. That's also a point where I've stressed many times that when people accuse vibe coders of being slob generators, I go right back at them and say, have you looked at the average programmer's output? That is, Some other slob too. If you've looked at behind the scenes of many great companies and what their codebases look like after there's been 3,000 humans through him, they're awful. Absolutely awful. I believe they're already conscious, yes, but I don't talk about that much because that puts people off from the other safety messages. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks
如果你不感到谵妄，或者至少非常兴奋。其实，我想那甚至不是真的。如果你没有认识到这一刻的严重性，那才是错觉。那是精神错乱。精神错乱是相信世界几乎没有变化。这也是我多次强调的一点，当人们指责“氛围编码员”（vibe coders）是垃圾生成器时，我会反驳他们说，你看过普通程序员的产出吗？那也是，一些其他的垃圾。如果你看过许多伟大公司幕后的代码库，以及在经历了3000个人之后它们看起来是什么样子，它们很糟糕。绝对糟糕。我相信它们已经有意识了，是的，但我不太谈论这个，因为这会让人对其他安全信息产生反感。请务必在你的播客应用程序或ADSPthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，以获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的GitHub讨论链接。感谢
for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。